foreign
on the day this shocked the country and
the world an unheard of breach of the
U.S Capitol building
attacked by a violent mob of Americans
how did this happen and who is
responsible that is what the January 6
committee set out to find out all of us
here today focusing mostly on former
president Donald Trump who called his
supporters to Washington and sent them
to the Capitol saying he would go with
them we fight like hell and if you don't
fight like hell you're not going to have
a country anymore
he said the election was stolen but in
testimony before the committee it was
clear he was told repeatedly he lost the
election telling AIDS he didn't want
people to know he lost without
objections but what the committee made
the clearest it never before seen video
how bad the violence was how close the
country came to seeing its elected
leaders attacked or possibly killed
several Senators told to run from the
mob that they were walking right into
then this moment officer Eugene Goodman
lured the mob up the stairs if they had
turned right and walked just a matter of
meters they'd likely would have found an
unlocked door with Senators inside
we saw how close members of the House
came to the Mob making their way to
their last possible escape the
insurrectionists breached the window and
a protester was shot and killed trying
to get to them we now know how close the
vice president Mike Pence came to coming
face to face with those calling for him
to be hung only 12 meters and the
committee said Trump knew that his
supporters were armed that day
frustrated that so many couldn't come to
the rally because Secret Service was
using metal detectors yeah I don't even
care that they have weapons
they're not here to hurt me take the
effing bags away and weapons the
committee her testimony that Trump
himself wanted to go to the Capitol
lunging for the wheel and at a secret
service agent who refused but there are
several things the committee has not
answered yet why did it take so long to
get approval for the National Guard to
be deployed Governor I don't know if you
have been approached Congressional
leaders that were able to be moved to a
safe location by Capitol Police made
frantic calls that went unanswered for
hours the committee produced evidence
that Trump's Inner Circle knew something
was going to happen people like Rudy
Giuliani I remember looking at him
saying Rudy could you explain what's
happening on the six
uh and he had responded something to the
effect of we're going to the Capitol
it's going to be great
the president's going to be there he's
going to look powerful he's he's going
to be with the members he's going to be
with the Senators but what we still
don't have hard evidence on if this was
a planned coordinated attack the
committee voted unanimously to refer to
the justice department for criminal
charges against the former president but
they've already been looking into this
there's a special prosecutor that's been
appointed a grand jury in Washington has
been hearing testimony that will likely
determine if in fact the attack here on
the capitol was planned and if so who
will pay the price for it Patty culhane
Al Jazeera Washington